hi I'm mano marks developer advocate on
the Google Maps API team this is the
fourth video in a series of four
designed to show you how to get started
the Google Maps JavaScript API in the
last video I covered adding an API key
to your Google Maps API loader and the
various parameters that the loader takes
in this video I'll cover the basics of
map options and getting your Maps to
render on a page if you've been
following along with this video series
you have a text document with this code
in it as we walk through this basic HTML
page you'll see the basic declaration of
elements the first thing I want to point
out is the style element one of the most
common mistakes that developers make is
to not specify the size of the div that
contains the map if you don't declare a
size for the div them when the map is
created it will be created but it will
be invisible because the div is 0 this
isn't part of the Maps API it's a basic
part of how HTML and CSS work in the sim
in this sample we put the style inline
with the page in most cases however you
would like to link to a separate file
containing your style sheets for ease of
maintenance and reusability the next
thing you see is the script tag that
loads the Maps API I covered that in the
last video next we see the JavaScript
that adds the map to the page you'll see
we declared the map variable as a global
variable that's in case you need it for
other functions next there's an
initialize function this is where we
actually create the map and assign it to
a particular div in the initialize
function the first thing we do is create
a map options object there are two
required properties that for a map
options object they are zoom and center
so let me cover it in the first video in
the series as a reminder zoom 0 is
zoomed way out showing the map of the
whole earth hi zoom levels get you close
to the map and show more detail we also
talked briefly about Center in the first
video but as a reminder it sets the
center of the map as a lot long object a
Google Maps long object has two
properties latitude
naturally you'll see loading objects
again particularly in various kinds of
overlays like markers there's a whole
host of primaries that you can use an
inept options object for more
information check out the reference at
this URL going back to the
initialization function we create the
mount object and assign it to the map
canvas element there's nothing magical
about the name map canvas it's just one
that we've chosen and so it shows up in
all of our samples you can see in the
body element there's a div with the idea
map canvas which is where the map object
will render lastly we add a Google Maps
Dom listener this is a dumb listener
that waits for the page to load and
triggers an initialize function that
will prevent the map from wandering
before the page is ready okay that's it
you have the basics you need for
creating a map if you are having any
trouble getting your map up and running
you might consult this video on
troubleshooting and common issues and
our support page has links off to the
right tags on Stack Overflow